- Welcome back!
- I'm so happy to be here!
(audience cheering)
- Go ahead its all right.
It's alright.
Do you get that just
when you enter Target?
People are just like, "wow!"
- I wish.
- So wait, do you get into Christmas?
- Oh, I love love Christmas.
It is my favorite holiday.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- [Michelle] I love it!
And we usually spend Christmas in Hawaii.
- Which is kind of different.
- [Michelle] It is.
- Not very snowy.
- Not very snowy, but nice.
It's where Barack is from,
so that's where his family is.
And because it's so far away
it's really the time we
get to spend with them.
So it's become a tradition.
- I love Hawaii.
Do you love Hawaii?
- That was half the reason why I said yes.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
In-laws,
beach, sun.
It's like, "I think I love you."